[Música]
hablamos ahora de salud en directo
américa france24 ya está conmigo en el
estudio más romeros a la mar la
organización mundial de la salud celebra
su asamblea en ginebra le pregunto que
debemos saber de lo que se dice en el
organismo pueden ser buenos días raúl
efectivamente esta asamblea es el
principal encuentro de la organización
mundial de la salud va del 22 al 28 28
perdón de mayo y vamos a repasar las
principales noticias la primera es la
reelección de pedrosa canon de bray es
uso como director de la organización
mundial de la salud por cinco años más
en lo que será su segundo y último
mandato no es en realidad una noticia
muy novedosa porque era el único pues el
único que estaba optando a ser reelegido
pero pues la verdad es que ha tenido un
apoyo bastante unánime a pesar de
ciertas asperezas con su país de origen
etiopía debido a que su gobierno
considera que tiene vínculos con las
fuerzas rebeldes del tigre y votaron en
contra pero aparte de este caso pues en
general ha tenido un gran apoyo sobre
todo pues porque ha sido el director que
tuvo que manejar la panda una de las
crisis sanitarias más inesperadas y se
consideran general que la organización
mundial de la salud reaccionó deprisa
que logró erigirse como una cierta
autoridad en momentos de incertidumbre y
además pues pedro se ha convertido una
de las caras más reconocibles de estos
últimos dos años y medio precisamente le
preguntamos a francisco becerra que es
ex subdirector de la ups cómo valoraba
este mandato
creo que el tener el y dar la cara casi
diariamente
apoyado por la gente que trabaja en el
departamento de infecciones de
emergencias este ha sido muy importante
de que ha viajado tratando de
entrevistarse con líderes de poner en
primer plano la relevancia de la
pandemia y creo que eso es importante en
cuanto a su labor ahora le pregunto en
términos de financiación se ha llegado a
alguna resolución pues así y una de las
más esperadas no una de las críticas a
veces que recibe la organización mundial
de la salud es que una proporción muy
grande de su financiamiento viene de
partes privadas de organizaciones
privadas por ejemplo la fundación bill y
melinda gates es prácticamente el
principal financiador de todo el
programa de erradicación de la polio
mientras que en cambio la proporción de
contribuciones obligatorias de los
países ha ido disminuyendo como vemos
2012 por ciento en estos últimos dos
años y ese dinero es el que realmente la
organización mundial de la salud puede
decidir cómo usar porque las
aportaciones privadas se acuerda cómo
usar ese dinero con el donante de los
fondos de dinero es entonces uno de los
acuerdos ha sido subir en los próximos
años esta financiación al 50 por ciento
lo que se ha celebrado como una forma
para dar más autonomía frente a estas
organizaciones privadas para el manejo
del dinero de la organización mundial de
la salud mar y por supuesto como no la
pandemia ha tenido protagonismo en esta
asamblea sí pues no podría ser de
ninguna otra manera especialmente
también porque ha sido la primera
asamblea que se ha celebrado de forma
presencial después de dos años y sobre
todo se ha hablado de cara al futuro no
de como prepararse para futuras
emergencias ha habido mucho debate
alrededor de las regulaciones
internacionales para cómo responder
coordinadamente también algunas críticas
algunas tensiones entre países de
ingresos bajos en países de ingresos
altos porque por ejemplo el bloque
africano se sintió algo presionado que
se abría la puerta a que los países de
ingresos altos como estados unidos
pudieran fiscalizar mucho sus respuestas
ante estas emergencias pero bueno la
verdad es que todavía no hay
conclusiones se han establecido grupos
de trabajo para los próximos años y
precisamente también nada por eso le
preguntamos a francisco becerra
es imprescindible para futuras pandemias
a según su opinión lo que necesitamos es
un fondo global para la respuesta
pandemia y que los países y la propia
oms puedan acceder a esos fondos para
poder hacer frente a los paneles creo
que contar con un financiamiento global
que esté depositado en el banco mundial
que esté creando intereses que esté
creciendo y que esté disponible para
cuando tengamos que enfrentar la
siguiente ola de una pandemia creo que
sería muy bueno para hacer frente a todo
esto y en el ínter tener un plan de
desarrollo fortalecimiento de respuesta
a pandemia que nos podría ayudar para ir
fortaleciendo los países más necesitados
y más de clics para terminar mar le
pregunto si se ha mencionado por
supuesto el conflicto internacional
del momento la guerra en ucrania sí pues
ha sido de hecho un tema de conflicto de
cierta tensión en la asamblea finalmente
la organización mundial de la salud
aprobó una resolución que digamos que
favorece el lado que apoyaba a ucrania
en estos
en el sentido de que responsabiliza a
rusia de la agresión contra trabajadores
e instalaciones de la salud y también
del empeoramiento de la situación de la
salud de los ucranianos y de la región
que ya hemos hablado en esta sección
también varias veces rusia por su parte
había propuesto otra moción en la que no
mencionaba su rol ni su responsabilidad
en estas empeoramiento de las
condiciones de la salud pero la verdad
también es importante decir que a pesar
de que pasó la resolución a favor de
ucrania fue con muchas abstenciones y
con muchas ausencias para terminar en
este sentido también vamos a recordar
que la organización mundial de la salud
ha registrado
235 ataques contra instalaciones y
personal de la salud desde que empezó la
invasión en ucrania mar como siempre
gracias por toda la información de salud
nos vemos el lunes con más salud en
directo marca de france 24 pasamos a
nuestra sección de limitado el día